grandparents that got married through
shotgun weddings
people used to have unplanned
pregnancies they'd just get married
after oh wow
i'm not saying it's common in my culture
but
it's
known i don't say i don't use the word
common but it is known for that to
happen just so that when the child is
born they can say that the child is born
through wedlock
yeah in nigeria that's i think this is
still practice to this day if you get
the girl pregnant you better marry that
woman because the other family's not
gonna have none of it yeah yeah yeah
you got my daughter pregnant you're
marrying my daughter within that nine
months you get me yeah
it is what it is and
in honesty
this is why
i think growing up i was more of a
liberal
but now i'm teetering towards the i'm
becoming a black conservative
i'm trying to see that a lot of these
these these liberal ideologies create
more problems in their solving society
this willy-nilly unstructured way of
living is not conducive to a successful
life
and we're starting to see the
consequences of that the liberals are
amassing way too much power and there's
a lot of problems that's happening in
society as a consequence of that because
humans need structure we live by
structure
everywhere you look there's a structure
and liberals are destroying that
structure
and nothing's coming to replace it but
what replaces structures anarchy and
we're going into a state of anarchy now
when did you become conservative
do you know what i think probably today
right here right
today right here right now you know what
it is i've always had conservative
conservative ideals but i felt like i
felt like my my liberal ideals
outweighed my conservative ones because
going to university i did international
relations i studied a lot of political
theory and stuff like that um i i
studied a lot to do with like um
psychology and help and to understand
how people's minds work and i think
coming from a poor background it's easy
to fall into that liberal mindset you
know that you know things happen to me
and because i'm black and you know but
you start to realize that
of course um you can't ignore the fact
that these things exist and i do have to
work slightly harder to get into other
positions that people that of not my
race might might get easily but that
doesn't necessarily mean that i can't
make something of myself comfortable and
and and then invoke stuff like nepotism
to benefit people around me because
that's just what we do so the liberal
mindset puts you in a state of you know
it's everybody else's fault so you take
no responsibility for for actions that
you commit and you can see that now
we're having a conversation about women
it's this liberal ideology that
nothing's ever your fault and you know
there's always something that's going to
come to look after you when in reality
we have structures in place to prevent
these things from happening so that we
don't have to to go to plan b like it's
called the precautionary principle if
you don't understand the consequences of
something you don't do it but a lot of
people don't follow the precautionary
principle when they do things anyway and
it's just going
it goes left but i think
coming on this show
has just helped to
it when i think about how i think now
my values are a lot more conservative
than they are liberal
so really i should just
so you're saying this show made you a
contribution
listen it helps
listen
i have a quick question for eddie so you
grew up nah did you say nigeria yeah
yeah yeah okay then so um you grown up
nigerian yeah is it because of your
background is that why you think you
fell into the
automatic ideology of liberal liberal
my parents are in this country as a
consequence of that and the support that
the labor government gave at the time so
like my parents now yeah are
automatically labeled no matter what
labor does or whatever they say i
thought it was just my parents as well
yeah literally they're labeled no matter
what happens and
i one of the one of the times was that
the votes happened i've heard green
party because i'm a i'm a big
environmentalist as well
and they're like why did you vote green
party vote labor because you know labels
are the only one that can save us i
think they ain't doing nothing right now
yeah i thought it was only my parents
that said that
they they're committed but again like
not say my parents are are dumb or
anything but they're this ignorant of of
the current dynamics of the world they
have their perception of what they grew
up with and that's all that exists yeah
and that's not the reality of the world
we need to make informed decisions and
that's why democracy doesn't work
democracy doesn't work because you don't
have an educated population to make
informed decisions about current affairs
people fall into this pseudo cultures of
group identities and then they make the
wrong decisions based on just being a
part of a group yes the world democracy
doesn't work that way and because we
live in a world governed by democracy
the world don't work that way so
people just need to get wiser and
liberalism doesn't do that yeah that's
why women we should give back our right
to vote
is that what you think
i'm not gonna lie i think about it
i don't think i could when the last
voting thing happened i don't think i
was eligible for it yeah but then should
i have voted yet i don't know if i would
i feel like i would have i've avoided i
have a green party or democrats because
like i said coming from an african
background as well as a black female
label's not doing nothing my mama oh
this is the man that they be like yes
let's go for life by yes yes yes let
everybody do nothing and that's what i
think i think i was actually hoping for
the democrats to win
i don't know i think because i have a
democrats or green party i can't
remember but i know it was one of the
two i wanted them to win you have
democrats here yeah we got the liberal
democrats oh okay they're the liberals
is it is it the same as the u.s liberals
no it's slightly different but
basically we got
the what's it we got the labor we got
the conservative and then i think
liberal democrats is in the middle well
but yeah he says again these both
parties there's the problem having a
two-party state anyway but those parties
are becoming more centralist anyway so
they're essentially saying the same
thing in different ways so okay
devil's advocate women give back the
right to vote okay
but i think about it okay
women we're chemically different every
single day
and you see the media playing into
getting the women's right to vote
because that's why whenever there's a
big election coming up that's why you
see
like we then there's a big election
coming up in the states in november and
roe versus wade just happened to get
leaked six months before they're trying
to get women to the polls
i'm like we're too easily controlled as
women i think in general
so i always say i'll take one for the
team to get the outcomes that i want
because i think elections would go more
my way the thing is i don't i don't this
as well i've got to be careful saying
what i say but i don't think you're
necessarily wrong in that because
this is part of what i studied at
university as well as like information
and decision science so
there's a guy called edward bernays and
they call him the father of pr
and he was able to manipulate my
psychology to to kind of gear in
whatever way he wanted so i think at the
time
there was a cigarette company that he
worked for and there's a lot of um
i think the women will fight for the
right to vote etc at around that time as
well um but he wanted to grow the the
sales of this particular company called
lucky stripe so what did he do he went
for the women so he basically created a
campaign that made the cigarettes a
torch of freedom
and then changed the color branding of
the cigarettes to the latest fashion of
that year yeah
and with that skyrocket itself and a lot
of the kind of advertising um
ways that we follow today are from this
guy called edward bernays so he was able
to manipulate my psychology
to boost the sales of this particular
company and that's what they do all the
time well women own two-thirds of
consumer debt we we make more emotional
decisions in general more impulsive
decisions yeah and it's hard because
there are women like obviously i would
imagine if we took away women's right to
vote then the women couldn't run for
office right and there are women like
nikki haley i don't know if you you you
guys probably don't know who that is but
she's a kick-ass woman i would totally
vote for her
but and so but
again i'm like i think we would all take
one for the team
to get the outcomes that we wanted yeah
and the majority of women didn't want
the right to vote
why because
it came with responsibility
that's what oftentimes women as women we
want the benefits without the
responsibilities and that's what
feminism always does is they always want
the benefits of being a woman without
any of the responsibility